have you been using kafka and been
really excited about the progress you
were making but wondering hey how can i
scale this usage out on a much larger
scale
well if so you're going to love our
topic today on event endpoint management
hello my name is jamil spain ibm
developer advocate and brand technical
specialist in the u.s financial services
market
to cover the topic of event endpoint
management i wanted to bring out four
major tips that you can use to which
really encompasses the discipline of
describing and managing your event
topics here so we're going to start off
by filling these in and we'll discuss
these points as we go the first
is that
these
event topics need to be described
now there's a specification called the
async api which is the
pretty much the industry standard on how
to describe events as topic or topics as
events
which is industry standard here and what
it really aims to do is give
events the same comfort as we have grown
to love
with apis and let's face it now
developers will want to implement apis
but they love to have that kind of that
swagger interface that they can quickly
go ahead and and start to go which
brings me to my next point
events should be
discoverable
and what this entails is
kind of the catalog format of having all
the events in one place tag with a
taxonomy so it's easy for me to search
and and cataloged and and very
presentable for me to actually go in and
read the specification for again another
great trend that we're used to for a lot
of api developer portals the fourth
we're going to say is
you should have
so i'll say that you'll have
decentralized access here so what this
pretty much says is people should be
free to explore all right the innovation
usually comes
where i'm i'm free to kind of go out and
and use it at my own comfort i kind of
equivocate it to like when i'm on
netflix i get to browse the catalog and
really find the movies as i want to go
kind of getting my own rabbit hole here
some of the trends that go along with
that is the capability to be
self-service where i get to register my
applications and truly have some way to
have trackable usage on what i'm using
getting that feedback there as well and
the last is
decoupled access so we really want to
find a way that's very scalable and less
fragile again the information or kafka
as a whole the the the process of
providing access to event topics should
not really impede on how i'm forced to
implement it here and so by putting this
interface in front that will really give
me a scalable way that i can expose
access to this and still accomplish what
i'm trying to do inside my architecture
here so hopefully that describes the
general arena of managing events
and the things you need to pay attention
to and watch out for let's move over to
the right and do a little diagram about
really depicting what it looks like and
how it works so for this let's start out
with our usual
diagram that everyone knows which is how
api management works
and again that we we already know that
apis get socialized uh let's say i am a
user and i'm sitting at my laptop and
i'm going to be looking at a
developer portal
we'll call that acronym.dp um and then
there's the concept of a gateway all
right api gateway and
now as i browse in the developer portal
i see something that i want to subscribe
to basically when i go to implement
i'm going to be actually going consuming
through the api gateway and as we know
it has an interface to go out
and hit some other
back-end service
as is
so that's a normal practice that's
that's always there again all the apis
are described in the developer portal
but this let's put these these
particular uh initiatives to to work
here when event endpoint management
comes into play let's switch our marker
here so with events
we're still going to have the same
developer portal here
a portal that describes and lists all
our particular events as they go and
we're also going to have the concept of
a
gateway so let's call it the ev the
event gateway
all right so as i am still being the
user let's take the same user so they're
looking at apis and alongside that they
have access to also browse topics here a
third tier that they can do
which will then as they go to consume
these
will go through the api gateway
and then be able to
consume from
kafka there
and provide the particular information
back as they would do so by using the
developer portal developers get to
quickly scale up and and and be able to
um look at the events that are there and
know be able to test it out quickly
implement and get going and as you
become your kafka become kafka as a
service or a very
kafka first environment where you want
to expose a lot of data directly through
event topics this is a great way with
event endpoint management to really get
that program going and facilitate that
so thank you for your time hope it was
very useful in your
in your use of kafka here and i look
forward to hearing your stories about
how you'll be using event endpoint
management in your architecture thank
you
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe